foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what would you do with this assignment
of defense was transferred to you
[Applause]
I promise you probably had successes
[Music]
this is my uniform
I'm not defense Victory too long
what is your name Napoleon
the course of my life just changed
Napoleon
[Applause]
I'm destined for greatness
but I was in power only see me as a
sword
I suggest you take the throne
shall we vote
this learning has held the world of
Hostage with his egotism and his lack of
simple good manners
Old Europe is nothing forces against me
what's the outcome of this you don't
succeed
emergency we are discovered good
first two admit when I make a mistake
I simply never do
foreign
[Music]